normal i mean you've seen these normal
distributions right that's what would
happen if it runs through
a community but when you start doing
all of this which are the interventions
then you can
you know ideally try and change the
shape of that and that's what china has
actually done um to my surprise uh
as as it was one of those things that
you know we spent 20 30 years in this
business it's like
seriously going to try and change that
with those tactics and and yes and and
it was successful
um or it is being successful because
look where the cases are driven
right now and one of the things we
looked at was okay well if that curve
would go like that you know
big question mark how many cases have
been prevented
or or or at least delayed as a result of
this action
and you know rough back of the envelope
you know we
look at it it's hundreds of thousands of
people in china
did not get coveted 19 because of this
aggressive response
and any time you pull down the force of
infection from the epicenter in an
outbreak like that
you are going to reduce the probability
of it going elsewhere as well
that was the other big thing we heard
again and again from
anyone in china was it's our
responsibility
to do this for the world not just for
for for them so we we heard that um
quite a number of times so the question
then became
um okay because we'd heard before
getting there of course
are the is this real and you know one of
the comments i made yesterday was
we know the numbers have bounced around
as as they've gone down and people have
asked questions what's going on today
how come the numbers have gone up etc
and you know what we as epidemiologists
are interested in it's not the exact
number on an exact day we're interested
in the trend and you want to know
is that trend real is this going down is
it stable or is it going up because
there were questions about
things aren't being shared etc and so
when we dug into that
we looked at you know multiple different
there's multiple different ways you can
try and get a sense of where the trend
is going
and one thing you can do is you can talk
to doctors who are seeing patients
who are running these massive uh
hospitals and
you know everywhere you were hearing the
same thing
that you know we have open beds and
in wuhan it was like we have open beds
we can get
people out of you know isolation centers
into a proper hospital bed we're able to
you know the system is opening up
because a number of cases are
are going down um you know one
indication
another one we looked at was they've
established what they call fever clinics
and these are places where if you have a
fever you go
and they assess you and they do a ct
scan very quickly
they do to see whether or not you've got
the tell-tale
marks of covet-19 disease and
um which is amazing story itself
but uh and then and then at these fever
hospitals then a decision is made they
do the test
whether or not you need the test and
then they do the test and then whether
or not you need to be isolated in a
facility etc
so uh the another thing we looked at
well how many people are getting tested
because what's happened is
um as people have you know this
mobilization of the community has
happened
there's been more and more people who
want to be tested quite frankly
and so they've been going and getting
tested the numbers have been going up
and up and up in terms of people getting
tested
initially and at one point it peaked at
about i think 46 000 people were being
tested
almost daily across the country huge
numbers and then it's down
when we looked at about a week and a
half ago down to 13 000 it was going
down like that
when we went and talked to the people at
the fever clinic you know they were
sitting there
not scanning people or not testing
people
and they said you know this is a change
we had lines and
and they aren't there anymore that's the
second indicator that that is real it's
coming down
and then a third indicator which was
interesting i i spoke to
um and again i mentioned this yesterday
so sorry to be redundant
um a a fantastic researcher a man called
ciao bin
who is running a rem deserver trial on
severe and mild cases
in wuhan and it's being done in wuhan of
course because that's where you have the
highest number of cases
you get the fastest enrollment and we
try and get an answer on this
um uh you know interesting drug as
quickly as possible
and uh so so when i was talking to him i
said so
how's enrollment going and he said it's
a challenge it's slowing down
it has slowed down because there are not
enough new patients that we can actually
recruit into the trial
so you know this all comes back to that
question of
is this real is what i described you you
know this
extraordinary mobilization to implement
fundamental public health principles and
approach in the absence of a vaccine or
a
uh or or drugs you know in the presence
of a respiratory disease
can this bring this down and it can
and that's the core message right we're
we're getting new reports daily of new
outbreaks in new areas
and people a sense of oh we can't do
anything and people are arguing is it a
pandemic or not
well sorry why don't you go look at have
you got a hundred beds where you could
isolate people if you have to
have you got a wing of a hospital that
you're going to close off have you got
30 ventilators because you're going to
have to help keep the severe cases alive
for
you know they'll recover but they're
going to need to be ventilated for four
or five days or or a week
you know do you have those pieces do you
know who your thousand case
you know contact tracers are these
there's really
practical things you can do to be ready
to be able to
uh respond to this and and that's where
the focus will need to be so we looked
at this um
and said okay that first question i told
you about what was done
the second what was the impact um and
and and the impact
was was striking oh i showed yesterday
another graphic which
might just be useful for people because
in some ways this is more striking than
the national one
so what you see here this is the same as
when you just saw these are the data for
all of china right
so going up fast fast fast like that
abrupt plateau and then the skewing as
it goes down
rather than up like that a bell curve
and down
out like this but then if you look at um
and you can see this is uh this is uh
wuhan right here which was really
driving the main shape of that
then these are the other areas of uh
hubei and this is china outside of hubei
and remember there's a lot more people
who live outside of the province of
hubei
than live in who may but this is a much
smaller
curve number one the other thing the
shape it's a very flat curve as well
part of it's a scale but this is not the
shape
of a normal epidemic and that happens
when you
do something to try and change it which
is what
china has managed to do and what's
striking is
how far down they've gotten it if i
remember yesterday
someone told me um i've heard
so many figures i think i've heard more
figures than there are people in china
over the last
two weeks but i think one of the figures
i heard yesterday was that
zero out of 20 or sorry 24
provinces had reported zero cases for
a day um and that's remember there were
31 provinces infected only
uh only uh three weeks ago again
evidence and all of these are as big as
any one of the countries that have been
uh you know in the news recently with
their outbreaks
and that's a very hopeful thing which
brings us to the third
thing that we were looking at is okay
where do you go next with china
where do you go next with the uh with um
this in terms of of of uh of the global
response
um and and and and one thing to mention
first is that
you know china were not uh um
acting from scratch china had had the
sars
epidemic an outbreak rather remember in
2003
and they realized they had to set up
surveillance for
uh atypical ammonias and and other
surveillance systems that they needed to
be able to do
case finding and contact tracing you
know at a much larger scale etc
so they had had time and experience to
build a system
but in terms of where they go next in
china and
you know having seen so much of what
they were done it was a little bit um
humbling to be asked for opinions about
okay where we go next
and a lot of it was really reinforcing
what what china is already doing and the
first piece of it is
you know the vigilance cases are down
but they're not zero
there is still a lot of uh disease in in
in the country that that's got to be
dealt with and remember
the people who get sick they remain in
hospital
or in a in an isolation center for
anywhere from two to six weeks
so it's a long period of time so if you
have
all of these people that got you know
um actually let's use this one so if you
have all of these people
let's go back a few weeks so if we go
back two or three weeks right so you're
back here
if you have all of these people that
were sick at that time
and you've got to add some of the ones
who were sick because that's just who
were sick on that
day or that week remember so then you
got to add the ones before
so an awful lot of those people are
still
in hospital or holding center um or
holding center permea you know an
isolation center
so uh right now the number if i remember
correctly yesterday was was just over
50 000 people um are still recovering
from covered 19
across uh across uh china
but uh well one of the other things we
learned though
is the spectrum of the disease you know
there's been a lot of question about
okay what is really the spectrum of
disease that this causes
what's the natural history of it we got
a lot of information there because of
just the sheer numbers uh now and and as
the epidemic or the outbreak goes
forward and they start to get control
there's time to analyze a lot of that
information more clearly
so now they can generate and and this i
take absolutely no credit for this this
nice piece of work but this was done
by um the centers for disease control
for the report
and what they've done here is try to
help people be able to visualize well
what proportion are mild or common um
when when they're when they're found
what proportion are severe and what
proportion are critical
uh uh critically ill patients and i
think you have a sense now
like the mild cases may just have a
fever and a cough and
and and by the time you get to the
common they usually have a pneumonia and
they're a bit sicker but
frankly they're still mobile and and in
good shape
um the severe are the ones by the
simplest way to say that is the next
step is they usually have
um respiratory insufficiency of some
sort like their
oxygen saturation is going down their
breathing rate is going up etc
and then the criticals usually have by
then often multi-organ
failure and uh what we you're able to
see from this is okay what proportion
fall into each group and you can see
80 percent are mild and
of those and a really important insight
from china is well how many of those
will go on to severe disease or even
death
you can see from the milds and the
commons very small
proportion this is really mild with
pneumonia with severe or larger and the
worst outcomes of course in the critical
but now we're getting to the sheer
weight of numbers that help us
understand that that's really important
because
you've got a plan how many beds might
you need how long are you going to need
them for
what are the outcomes going to be like
how many are going to become severe and
you're going to need
possibly ventilation etc these are
really important
things to be able to plan that also if
you want to plan a clinical trial
you need to understand well would they
get worse without the drug or not would
they go for it so
you need this kind of information is is
so important
and china right now are the only ones
who have been able to generate
with the kind of numbers to be able to
uh to help us under understand that
but what it means is they still have 50
000 cases as we mentioned
the thing is any new cases now they
generally know where they've come from
they can link them epidemiologically or
link them to a contact and that's when
you know
as you've heard from ebola that that's
when you know you're getting control of
a
of a situation you're not getting cases
from
out of the blue and you can't link them
back uh which is is
is what's sometimes so concerning um
so that's the first thing the second big
thing which is a really important
message from china is
every governor we talked to you know
that most of them
they had an epidemic curve that was
going down like that
and what were they doing in response
building hospital beds buying
ventilators and being prepared
that's what they were doing they were
saying okay look we just repurposed
hospitals that
should be giving general care if these
cases go back up again and that was
always what they came back to
we don't know this virus people are
talking about sars
or they're talking about flu and as soon
as we get stuck with those
that two binary you know approaches and
ways of thinking
we're not preparing for the novel clone
providers we're comparing preparing for
that or preparing for this
but we're not using all the evidence
that we have and
and one of their key points they made
again and again was
we don't know what's going to happen
next in china we've got it right down
like this
we think we can manage and there will
not be another wu hum we know how to
manage this disease now in all the parts
of the country
if it went to zero and disappeared
that'd be great but that's not what
they're planning for what they're
planning for is this could remain for
some time
maybe some time to lose a vaccine so we
will have the capacities to be able to
manage it
and run society and economy and
everything else the way we need to
and not lock people down to try and and
and and manage this so that's the second
big thing they're doing but it's a good
message for the world right um
how many countries are you know planning
hospital beds planning
ventilators planning you know o2 uh
supplies and and and the lab capacity to
be able to
manage this and then the third thing
that uh
you know we we said and asked of china
you know at this point
the world needs the experience of china
and
china has dealt with the most disease in
the world 31 provinces have managed this
everyone we spoke to they knew what they
were doing and they've clinically
managed
huge numbers of cases now um
and you know one of the points you heard
me mention yesterday is
countries are building barriers between
themselves and china
and new barriers are going up in the
last days
at a time when the cases and the risk
from china are going down
and you need access to that expertise
that much more
you also need china and it's it's
getting its productivity going as you've
heard
they're getting they're doing a phased
restart of everything so they're getting
the um uh um
uh you know the factories going um then
eventually
they'll they'll get the schools going
and then they'll but they're taking a
phased approach to try and manage the
uh the um the startup now as they go
forward um so for china there were a
number of
of suggestions about how to move forward
um and a lot of it was reinforcing some
things that were already happening
um but then for the rest of the world uh
and that were those were the bigger
things that you heard me speak about
um uh yesterday perhaps but the first
thing
in the response is there has to be a
shift in mindsets
um again around the world people
are thinking oh gosh how do we live with
this and manage all this disaster etc
instead of gosh this virus is going to
come it's going to show up in our
country
we're going to find it within the first
week we're going to find every case
we're going to go after every contact we
are going to make sure that we can
isolate them and
keep these people alive so they survive
the case this is the way we've got to be
thinking it takes a real shift in
mindset
and it's not a preparedness mindset
which usually thinks about how you
prepare for eventual disasters
this is going to come soon potentially
you've got to be
shifting to a readiness rapid response
thinking
and you know in china one of the
interesting things was
not only did they designate a whole
hospital and these are big
modern facilities um hundreds of beds as
okay that one's going to manage it when
you go up and think okay how do you
actually do that in practice how do you
keep it safe
so you go to a ward you know if you go
to hoog here or to
la tour i'm sure most of you have
unfortunately had a visit to one of
those places
um you know you've got your awards right
with some doors at the beginning of the
ward well
what what china has done rather than
have some beds that are isolation beds
is at the start of that ward they built
a wall with a window on it
they sealed the whole thing and said the
whole ward
all that whole 40 beds 100 beds is now
an isolation unit
just everything at scale very very fast
they've taken a stadium which which i
saw
they put a thousand beds up 72 hours
you know it's you've seen these
hospitals being built over a week
but they went from uh they would convert
a training center or
a stadium in uh between 24 and
72 hours that was the time frame they
took in wuhan to
increase by a thousand their capacity
and it was it was such a disciplined
approach
uh to put to put that in place but again
a good lesson
it's okay we're going to try and not
have woohans to deal with wuhans
obviously
but you may have to deal with sporadic
cases definitely we're seeing that in
many places they get sporadic cases
we're also seeing clusters of cases and
as soon as you start seeing that in
places
you have to be ready to manage this at a
larger scale
and you have to be ready you know in
your mind to stop the transmission
change you have to be thinking that way
and and and so there has to be the
mindset shift number one
and there's got to be the readiness
planning and capacity building
and it has to be done fast um so
yesterday when i said you know
second big conclusion for the world is
it's simply not ready
um but it could get ready very fast but
the big shift has got to be in the
mindset about
what we're gonna how we're gonna manage
the disease
the third big thing you know the rest of
the world and and probably this
is the first one is you've got to get
your population ready and bring your
population with you and your populations
you know
they should be washing their hands now
they should be proper
you know hygiene now those things that
we should be doing
anyway should be at scale in countries
because they will
make a difference to the spread of a
respiratory border disease
but you've got to bring your population
with you and your population you want to
bring them with you early
because things are going to change
rapidly
and they've got to have a trust in a way
in a machinery to keep people up to date
yes we said that we have new information
now we do it this way
because it's we have known this virus
for
seven weeks so we are going to have to
adapt as we get uh the um the
the strategy rolled out um and and and
the
you know the fourth thing i would say if
if
as we look at okay the rest of the world
would be
access the expertise of china and the
you know
they've done this at scale they know
what they're doing um and
uh they're really really good at it and
they're really keen to help
um even though they are still working in
their own areas
and this was another message that you
heard all the time in china it was a
fantastic story of
um the human side it was always about
the people and the individuals uh
everywhere you went uh from from uh
any anyone you spoke to and there was a
sense of responsibility
and silence sense of you know collective
action um and this war footing
to to get things done but um
the the the other thing that was
striking was the solidarity between
provinces
because remember every province in
in china has been hit by an unknown
pathogen that started to do this in the
province
their response was to get on top of in
their own provinces
but to send medical teams ppe
everything into wu on you know when i
met with the governors they said yeah we
just sent 2 000 people into wuhan
and uh to to to to work and you wonder
how does that even work right
so you go to the stadium and say well
how does that work and there's you know
one of the physicians says well i'm from
and uh from from
hanan or guangdong or wherever it was
and he says
we run that you know that one i told you
that was boarded off
we run that one they just bring a whole
team and run the whole thing
and they bring all their own ppe all
their own equipment they pull it out of
that
province and remember what we're seeing
in the rest of the world is oh we better
build up our stocks and keep it over
here oh we better keep this here we
better keep our
you know whatever but there's this sense
of you
get the resources where they're needed
it's in our common interest to get this
down and and you saw all the provinces
operating that way
it was really fascinating so those are
the big findings you know what china did
the real impact that it had the
implications are
you can actually affect the course of
this disease um you can
uh change the shape of this but it takes
a very
uh aggressive uh and and and and tough
uh program it it was a striking thing
uh to see as you know in in 30 years of
doing this business i
i've not seen this before and nor was i
uh sure it would work so we saw a bunch
of other things as well as i mentioned
there were a number of technical things
that we learned about disease severity
um the natural history of the disease
how it's transmitted by the way
um uh even
some of the work being done on the
ammunition very interesting
but then also operationally how do you
run a response like that right so
talking that through with top leaders um
how do you set up a stadium in
you know 72 hours and then walk through
you do one two three four i mean
that makes sense um and then and then
how you run these kind of containment
measures at the at this scale
so a lot of of really good learnings
that will inform
uh other parts of what we're trying to
do with this uh with this response
um i would say uh let me one point
because i know there'll be questions and
and i'll say as long as we need to try
and
help with any of those but one of the
big questions
that we keep hearing about and you will
have heard is about you know
how much transmission is going on in
communities right you keep hearing the
tip of the iceberg and we can't see this
thing and you know there's millions of
people infected and all this kind of
stuff
so we tried to look at those kind of
questions as well and we
um again you know you're at war here and
there's a huge fog
in any war you're trying to find those
little bits of information that can add
up and give you some confidence in what
you're saying
so we tried to look at um what
where was there sampling of people in
the population that might give us a
sense
of how widely this virus was was was
was spreading and again this is where
it's great to look at these things in
china because the numbers are so big
but um you've probably heard there's
something called an influenza like
illness surveillance system that runs
around the world with many sentinel
sites that collect like 20 samples every
month and
we get them analyzed etc but this
happens in multiple places of china
and what you could do is look at those
data and they could show you here our
data are sampling
here's all the flu cases that were
coming up and in november
uh december of last year they all went
back to look
nobody because then when once we had a
you know coven 19 test they went back to
test all of these
nobody found it it wasn't there they
found lots of flu
but then in january they did find it it
comes up in january
the the first couple of weeks of january
but outside of uh
hubei very rare one might be positive
here or one there wasn't like all these
samples were
were positive like there was a lot of it
circulating um
and then uh another thing we did is in
in places that were heavily infected
more and more people were coming to
fever clinics they wanted to get tested
et cetera and in one place it might even
guandong i think
they had tested 320 000 uh
samples for uh uh
the clovid virus um 320 000 right it's
going to give you some sense of what's
going on
and when they started the sampling of
those about
.4 nine i think it was percent of them
were positive so less than
you know half a percent and in the
recent period
it's something like 0.02 so i know
everybody's been out there saying well
all of this thing is spreading
everywhere and we just can't see a tip
of the iceberg but
the data that we do have don't support
that
and what it supports is sure there may
be a few asymptomatic cases
and that probably is a real issue but
there's not
a huge transmission beyond what you can
actually see
clinically and that's really important
right if you're in a war you will need
to be able to
see your enemy to to know what you're
dealing with
now another important development in
china just while we were there
was they've just licensed a couple of
zero assays that will let them test
antibodies
in a whole bunch of uh people to try and
get a sense of
if they have antibodies but they weren't
sick you know the virus was circulating
so you know maybe i'll be sitting here
next week and saying guess what
those data didn't tell us the story
these ones do but that zero survey
should help us
um understand that and that'll be
important for example you want to reopen
your schools you know that
kids have not gotten very sick or very
few have
have a lot of them been infected are
they part of the driver of this
uh outbreak it doesn't look like it
looks like the main driver is not
widespread community infection it looks
like it's household
level infection that may be part of the
reason that china's strategy
find the case because the close contacts
are families and people usually know
them
and you're going to be able to find them
and be more successful
and remember you don't have to find
every single one because you never will
you want to find enough to break the big
chains the transmission slow this thing
down and and get a grip on it
so that's um uh why we went uh
what we saw was being done the impact
that we believe it had and how we think
it can inform
the global response i want to highlight
again i am not speaking for who because
you know someone may be going what
but but that's what the evidence says
uh and you know when you're in a war
like this this is
um we we had a big debate with with some
of our chinese callings about
you know is this a dangerous virus is
this a serious virus is it whatever
the bottom line is this virus kills
people you've seen that
and it kills vulnerable people it kills
our elderly and
you know what we think of as society is
how we care for the vulnerable in our
populations not just and i hear people
say oh yeah but the young survive all is
good
you know seriously um and and
it is uh and and that's not always the
case either young people do die of this
disease as you've seen
as well and they die in industrialized
countries and
i think people were also looking
sometimes at this and saying
oh but in china you know they don't have
this they don't have that etc
you know if i had covered 19 i want to
be treated in china
you know we go into these hospitals and
and you know how many ventilators do you
have
50 60. i mean just a scale we're not
used to thinking on the rest and then
you'd ask you how many ecmo systems do
you have and i was like seriously you're
going to ask about ecmo you know this is
extracorporeal membrane oxygenation and
it's
to to when the lungs simply even if you
ventilate aren't gonna
get enough oxygen and and place would
say five and i remember being with
tim from the robert [ __ ] institute like
five from one hospital you know
we don't have that in europe and we're
using three of them to
uh and as and we were like well do they
people come out and they yeah
so when we look at how dangerous this
disease is as well i think we have to be
careful looking at the china data
because
china know how to keep people alive uh
from covet
they're super committed to it and
they're making a massive investment in
it as well
that's not going to be the case
everywhere in the world and as you've
seen we've had
tragically lost people in you know g7
countries
are are are dying of this disease
and uh so it is a serious uh
disease and i and i worry sometimes if
we look at the china numbers people are
going to get a false sense of security
these people know and they care about
keeping these people
alive and and they do it successfully
they're really good at it
so folks that's what we saw uh we've
heard what we think can help inform the
global response is never black and white
but sometimes
we'll present our reporting a little bit
more black and white in hopes that it'll
drive the discussion about where we go
next with the global response
so margaret no one looks interested so
they look for holidays
to look they're all raring to go bernard
i
i think a lot of you guys know bernard
schwartzander the chef de cabinet here
and he said
let's try and add up how much many hours
you slept in the last 14 days and
i i don't know it barely gets into the
double digits
so again sorry to run on so long but we
saw a lot and it's a complicated story
so i want to make sure you heard it
before i hear
what would be helpful to clarify thank
you very much dr ellwood i'd like to be
treated in china too
[Laughter]
so just to remind everybody those of you
online if you want to ask a question
dialstar9 and or
if you're using zoom uh put your hand up
on the
icon on the screen on your right we'll
start with questions from the room who
she's going to take from a question from
um i also want to thank those of you who
tried to contact me i saw jamie's ham
went up first
because people phoned me and called me
in in china and the rest
and and those of you who know me running
many crises i try to be extremely
available to the press because i just
think you're so
important to managing any crises it's in
my interest
and um in this occasion we went to a
complete you know blackout because we
really
had to focus on this we're we're trying
to
inform a global response and a danger of
escalating disease and
you know people would might call and say
well this happened there or that
happened there
you know it gets you off track we just
had to focus on what we're doing so so
thanks for the the patience for those of
you who are frustrated by that
okay i'm going to be very geometric
we've got four microphones one
two three four so i'll take a question
over here
from the corresponding from cgtn
terrible thank you shane from china
central television cctv
i have a question that is about
you mentioned china has been successful
in containing the virus and the
and the disease it's being yeah it's
it's showing success let's not put the
carp they're not putting the cart before
the horse if they said i said they're
contained the disease they'd have a fit
because yeah thanks for being precise
and careful sorry so my question is you
suggest that there are many things other
countries can learn from china
however do you think there will be some
difficulty for them for them to
accept to adopt all these measures that
why are there
such difficulties thank you
yeah i'm going to jump in on the
questions
it's a little bit like i said right
we've this is a respiratory boring
pathogen and when we think about things
like flu and the rest we think okay we
need a vaccine to manage that because
you can't get ahead of the transmission
of it so part of it's a mindset
shift that gosh this can actually slow
this thing down and frankly i think the
mindset shift is is the hardest part
it's really hard work too right kind of
easy to stick a vaccine in someone's arm
really hard to find every single case
and you got to find them super fast
and get you know find every contact get
them isolated
so there's going to be a range of of of
challenges one is going to be that
mindset shift
um the second is the communities and and
populations coming with it
because to accept quarantine to where
where it's needed to accept you know the
rapid isolation etc etc
you know these are are are going to be
challenges for for
people as well um and materially right
have we are we ready to isolate that
number of people to support that number
of people
etc so um there's a combination of uh
of of uh you know mindset issues
uh uh yeah i think community engagement
issues
uh and and just material issues but um
we've got to overcome them it's as
simple as that it's necessary because
it seems to be the only way right
it's a good way it works and for the
others
so so so let me say a word about that um
you know with ebola we have a vaccine
right but it's not going to replace
case finding contact phrasing i don't
know what the vaccine for this
might look like you know we have sars we
have murders we don't have
vaccines out we've got great candidates
but they're not out there working
they're coronaviruses right
and remember those are the six human
coronaviruses right now there's those
two and then there's the four that cause
common colds and things like you've
heard about
we're not great at coronavirus vaccines
i mean
the whole world of not people in the
world of coronavirus acts you're going
to slaughter me because
they're going to say we are great we're
just not using them but
um we don't have the experience we do
with flu with other other other diseases
so
um you know and china is very pragmatic
don't know if we're going to get it
we're going to work on it but we're
going to move this way um
that's where you heard again and again
so sorry let's keep moving here
okay another question from
okay stephanie
yes it's been two years i can't remember
which agency i'm sorry
right
um i wonder if i could draw you please
on um
infections among healthcare workers sure
what you're seeing in hospitals you were
in three provinces
have they do they haven't two parts do
they have enough equipment
are they you know in the training and
then secondly um
are they are you seeing transmission
still in healthcare
settings um there was a peak in january
but
even the scale of three thousand super
important question stephanie asked about
health care workers right because
if your health system goes down you
can't run your response early days of
ebola
in west africa it was one of the big big
challenges we had
and it's a common thing when emerging
disease nobody knows right it hits the
hell
you know it enters through the health
care system remember that's where a
virus is going to enter often because
they come in looking for care
and uh and all of a sudden boom it blows
up and if i remember correctly italy had
uh had uh had uh
had an issue so with that um
so in terms of china first on the
numbers of health care workers and and
this is a
rough um we always have to be careful
and differentiate
health care worker infections from
nosocomial outbreaks
so a nosocomial outbreak is an outbreak
in a healthcare facility right
and that can be patients infecting
healthcare workers patients infecting
other patients i mean there can be
different
ways it works and when you look at
healthcare workers people often think
oh that's an outbreak there most
healthcare workers got infected in the
community
not in the healthcare worker as you get
in there and you talk to people who
actually did that
they can tell you they say well no they
know people often knew where they got
infected
and you know the ones that are are are
in the press and rightfully so
are ones where it all may have happened
in a healthcare facility but the
majority hadn't so there had to be a
two-pronged approach to this
first was making sure that you run your
covid facilities
uh um safe and frankly that
that was was was being addressed
relatively uh early on
but then remember i told you so that's
your covet hospital right and this is
your hospital for
regular care okay so i'm pregnant don't
feel great
i'll go into the regular care hospital
or i've you know had
had chest pain and i'm having problem
breathing i'll go there
and you go into the regular hospital and
you've got
um in fact you've got covid and so a
number of the ones that were happening
were actually happening
not in the covid facilities but they
were uh
happening in in in the regular
facilities
um you know stephanie so so the first
thing you always have to do in these is
trying to figure out who's getting
infected how are they getting infected
where are they getting infected and then
and then try and fix it um and
again everywhere we went this was a
a top priority and when you went in and
looked at okay
how are you managing infection
prevention control you know all the
basics about clean channels
dirty channels um you know were in place
the supplies now largely in place yeah
we never found anywhere and there there
may still be some that where
people did say it was really tight and
there were periods where this was a real
problem
but um again when you look at the
distribution of the healthcare worker
infections most of them were much
earlier in the outbreak
and that's the other thing that's what
we're seeing i mean you've seen in the
countries that get reinfected
boom you get these uh um outbreaks
because they're not used to dealing with
with the
the disease but um are they taking it
seriously
absolutely are they good at it um
absolutely are the numbers coming down
absolutely in terms of healthcare work
or infections that's a good news story
within it
um but it also highlights something
that's a little bit different because
again we think sars flew right but this
is is
uh doesn't cause we haven't seen big
nosocomi
outbreaks like we have with the other
diseases right so
so something's a bit different you know
we're not seeing a lot of disease in
kids
you know look at flu you know all the
kids get sick right um
we're uh which is a problem because
remember one of the big problems with
flu all the kids get sick and that all
the parents have to stay home and then
you lose billions of dollars and
you know you're from your economy that's
how it works that doesn't happen
with with this disease and we never by
the way when we talked to people
we couldn't find an example where a
child
was the index case in a transmission
chain or had
you know led to the infection of an
adult now that might just be people's
recall or bias or whatever but it was an
interesting insight
because remember a lot of things that we
test in science
it comes from someone's observation and
and then you say okay is that
why is that so um did i cover that well
enough stephanie i'm sorry i'm kind of
rambling
because it's such an important issue
yeah i mean oh one other thing um nugget
uh so we're in wuhan and we we couldn't
go into the fever clinic because you put
yourself at risk and i was going to come
talk to you guys and i wasn't going to
put my family at risk
there's no need to but anyway the
but we could see where they started and
went in and got gowned and the rest to
go in
and we met this woman there who
explained the different stages and the
mirrors for how they check
are they gown properly etc and she
really knew she was she was so
impressive and so i said so you're like
an ipc expert she's like no
god i do something completely different
but i've learned all of this stuff this
is the most important part of what we do
you know you found this passion
everywhere um so you know stephanie that
was important because you wonder
are people getting sent into the line of
fire right without
the proper equipment and early in this
people were caught in war without the
right equipment that that's kind of
what sounds like it happened but then
you know because if you were coming in
from another province you had to bring
all your ppe
so you know these guys that sent in the
team from
you know on me or one of these other
provinces they came with you know tons
of equipment
they you had to be self-sufficient and
that was one of the issues with me going
in there and i was told that i said look
we have a principal no one goes in
without their own gear
and fortunately we bought a brought a
bunch of gear which was all sitting in
beijing which i told our rep
on the phone guess what that's all going
to the ministry tomorrow but that's how
it worked
and you found that discipline in
everything sorry
okay we'll take one more from this side
a gentleman there with his hand up
yes go ahead it's young with xinhua news
agency
from which one sorry uh young xinhua
news agency
uh with a with great efforts to uh to
the control and prevent
to the control of prevention of the
disease china is also trying to resume
the economic
activities so uh it's like a large
number of people
go back to the places to to where they
work so is there any uh
special aspects or any parts that
people should pay special attention to
when they go back to work and resume
their
uh economic activities and again the the
question yeah i was asking is so
important right so you get this thing
under control
then you get massive numbers of people
moving again because remember they've
all been
stopped right and and then they carry
the virus into these areas so a couple
of things have changed right
number one these areas are prepared they
know how to deal with this disease when
it springs up etc
the second is is that uh they they've
done a
phased reopening of uh of of the uh
the factories the the uh industries etc
and in phasing that they've been able to
manage the risk as as they've opened
more and more
of the economy it depends a little bit
on the province because most a lot of
them have done it a little bit
differently so some went
um you know like the week of 8th
february i think it was others went the
following week so
so it's been rolled out temporarily a
little bit different as well
but the other thing that they've done
and this was interesting in sichuan when
we met with the governor he said look
can we show you a video and
he said look this is really cool and i
said sure i mean we'll look at
everything
and he showed this video that they'd
made and and again
um all of the migrant workers what it
did was it was it was this video you
play on your phone and it it gave you
all this information if you're a migrant
worker from sichuan and you want to go
back somewhere
you have got to do x y and z and go to
the
one of these facilities get screened you
will get a certificate that's valid for
three days
and you show up and you know the next
city and then you will have to show that
and it can be scanned and uploaded etc
but there's a whole effort to manage it
um you know at the community population
level but also at the individual level
and and that five million people migrant
workers that they were going to run
through this system that was one
province
so it is a risk it's a it's and they
know it's a risk but
they've the economy's got to work it's
people have got to work
life's it's not life's got to go on it's
got to power the response as well
okay i'm going to go online now and ask
helen branson she can have her questions
hi bruce um
sorry i'm getting a reverb
um i would ask you right off the top
why you're not wearing a mask if you
don't mind but i
i would also ask you to uh
go into um what you were saying about
not finding much
undetected mild cases a bunch of us were
hoping that
uh there would be more of the iceberg to
be uncovered
to drive down the severity of
uh this outbreak and i think you're
suggesting that that's not true it's not
true it's not the fruit
not true yeah
we got your point through the echo um
yeah so
so so so first um
don't don't miss misquote me please um
the this is a serious disease there's a
lot of disease when you get a lot of
community transmission going on you know
tens of thousands of cases in this place
so that's a lot
um but what i've heard people say is
there's a whole bunch more of
transmission there's not a lot of
evidence of that
now we're going to do serologic surveys
there's a zero assay and we may find
that oh a lot more people were positive
a lot more people were
affected than we thought because
remember with flu right it's
10 20 30 40 of the the population will
have uh may have antibodies suggesting
that
that that they've been exposed um in in
a flu season
i'm not a flu expert so so if i've got
the numbers wrong but they're quite high
all of the sources of information that
we looked at helen like
for example we were very very interested
in
any kind of sampling that had been done
at a population level and in multiple
provinces
we could find okay we've sampled you
know 10 000 people or we've sampled 50
000
people in in in
let's say a uh just regular hospital
clinics or something like that
so this is convenience sampling right
it's not a study but
in those they were finding a very low
proportion of people
actually had the virus now there could
be reasons for that right because people
are
really restricted to their homes they've
you know closed restaurants closed
cinemas
uh et cetera et cetera there's all those
things which means
um you know and the goal was to break
that transmission
so um but as as things resume that
that's going to be a really important
thing to look at
but for that to happen helen remember
there would have to be a whole lot of
mild cases that you wouldn't find
and in wuhan now you know these people
don't want any more transmission they
want everybody isolated and break the
transmission change and they're going
house to house to check temperatures etc
they're probably not missing you know a
huge
a huge amount but not definitely orders
of of magnitude and then with you know
asymptomatics again
it doesn't look like that's a big part
of the picture
there was just no data that supports
that
so you know i have to make a judgment uh
you know helen between
what are the data that i have and what
are the speculations that i can make in
in
in
worst-case scenarios and the data
doesn't say that the bits of data we
have i may be wrong as we generate more
data but
but um you know all the data that we
have
suggests that there isn't this massive
uh uh the iceberg is you know you've got
critical cases you got severe cases you
got mild cases and a bit asymptomatic
transmission
probably at the bottom that seems to be
what it looks like but remember we've
known this disease for seven days
or seven weeks sorry i haven't slept in
seven days
it feels like straight does that help
we can go into jason jason but also by
the way
would you be able to do that to the
curve if this thing was going around
everywhere like that
and you couldn't see it hard to believe
and so i have to go with what i can see
okay i will go on to jason gayle oh she
asked why i wasn't wearing a mask
oh sorry sorry yeah sorry you know i
don't have covet 19.
i'm very low risk i you know i did i
and and you know i had an hour-long
grilling um
before i i did this when i came back
anyone coming back from travel has to
uh on the who side but um also i never
had any exposures you know
we were we are careful and we run
careful um
you know we have no uh contact with
patients we have no contact with
dire you know close contacts with no
contacts with contacts
we washed our hands every three seconds
we wore
masks all the time because we had to
wear masks
it's the government policy in the
country we're social distance we were
you know i told you we're
uh on trains and cars and everything one
person in a row
everywhere that's why i'm so hoarse
because you give a shout at everybody
when we had meals our meals were eaten
in the hotel rooms we weren't
all the restaurants were closed so we
weren't even interacting with our group
and then when we uh uh sometimes
uh there we were we were working and we
would
like we went to the cdc was between
meetings we went to the cdc cafeteria
for lunch
they had a table like this and then
another table like this one person at a
table there was one setting at each
table
and you weren't allowed to sit you had
to shout at each other
and then i told you the last day we were
having last
couple of days we were working on the
report so margaret would be on that
table you'd be on one table you're on
the next table and we had to use
microphones to run the meeting but
everything was distanced two meters
apart
and it you know it runs that way
there um and you know any of the
hospitals we went to we go into the
clean section
um and we go nowhere near you know
there's a dirty section and
there's also a gray zone we've got
nowhere near those things um
i'm trying to give some other examples
because i had to go right through all of
this
and then um because i was going out
through
uh um beijing to do the press conference
and beijing as you know
udacio about people returning to work
beijing put in place a policy
anyone coming back from any province is
automatically in a two-week quarantine
in uh beijing and that applies to us as
well
um unless we're in transit on the on the
way on the way out
and so what they said there's a lot of
negotiation about this when i got off
the train from wuhan into guangdong
i had a swab yesterday and they said you
know
we will we will test you've been in the
country for two weeks you're coming
through beijing and no
negotiated agreement for how we manage
this and uh
it was negative but um you know you know
uh
it comes back to a science and
evidence-based
approach uh to to what we're doing if
the evidence changes right and there
were any reason that i was at risk
um i wouldn't be wearing a mask i
wouldn't be sitting here
i'm not going to put a mask between me
and you guys if you think there's any
kind of wrist that doesn't make sense
i'm still taking another question from
online jason gale are you there with
your question
hey jason hey jason hey hey bruce lots
of feedback
so i will push ahead um you mentioned
learning more about the natural history
of this disease
disease disease how do you think it
typically starts and manifests
um so it it i th
that's a good question but as one speaks
to people what they remember is the
fever
of course um and uh and uh
uh in eighty-eight percent now now the
nice thing you know china is 55 000
cases in data on every single one of
them at the time
on set and what they report is 88 say we
had fever
68 say they had a dry cough and that's
important numbers because folks what
percent have a runny nose
throw a guess out there because you know
you always see people going around
sniffling and the rest of you worry oh
do they have cove at 19.
four percent you know it's not it's not
an upper respiratory tract infection
so but jason sorry back to your question
um so
uh they report that or they report just
the couple of days before
having what we call prodromal-like
syndromes they feel fatigued they
feel myalgia they feel unwell you know
it's just a general unwellness
so part of this is having a high index
of suspicion if you think you've been
exposed to someone
um because because they they they either
present with that
fever a dry cough or that prodromal
non-specific uh malaise uh
you know aches and and
fatigue
is that coverage jason jason uh uh
actually i wanted
to ask you what what's causing that
ammonia to progress to acute respiratory
distress syndrome and multi-organ
failure what do we know about that
that was interesting because a couple of
places had documented uh the data
uh fairly well it's not published yet
but what it looks like
about 80 percent of these are
as i mentioned mild at time of detection
about 13
uh severe at about six percent um uh
uh in in in critical uh condition
and then if you look at the percent that
progressed from one to another about 15
percent
seem to progress from mild to severe and
then from
severe to critical because i thought it
was a higher percent but it's about 15
to 20 percent uh
again jason that's what those numbers
look like um
and then if you look at the survival
rates per group that that's pretty well
published right uh
extremely high in in in the milds and
and then uh
i'd have to pull the numbers out but but
the the the high mortality obviously is
in the severes and especially
uh the criticals and here you have to be
careful right because people say well
what proportion of severe and critical
uh uh um
survive and you know okay so say it's 80
percent
in in chinese uh facilities or 90
percent
um that's not what it's going to be in
other places
they're really good at managing really
complicated disease
on big scale right now so i would not
have a false sense of security in the
numbers
okay one more online uh tammy bbc
i have
hello go ahead please go ahead please
sorry i don't know if you can hear me um
i would like to know what is your
responsibility
miles glowing
uh we didn't quite get your question was
that something about two hundred and
fifty
thousand really bad or two hundred could
you kindly repeat that one
that one that one what is your response
to miles glow telling steve bannon that
millions are infected and two hundred
and two hundred
yeah i think i i i um tammy i've not
seen whatever you just referred to so
again not dodging a question but i i
simply don't know what i'm
responding to um i heard two people
one of them said there's a million cases
and 250 000 dead
and being hidden in china or something
like that yeah
you know i didn't go to every single
place in every corner of china but
i think we have a pretty good sense of
of what the epidemic looks like and
i think these numbers are are reflective
of that
i mean but i i don't know where their
information comes from and again this
comes back
you know i get asked a lot of questions
well what about this and what about that
i've got to go with the data that we see
and anything that i told you
we tried to use multiple data points to
try and observations to try and
corroborate it right we didn't try and
like oh we heard that from someone let's
go with it we everything and the team
remember i told you was on this team cdc
nih
robert [ __ ] you know demands tops
institutes etc and they'll
sign off on this thing so they're pretty
rigorous
okay okay questions from the room oh you
got to let jamie ask
why soon he's been okay all right
poor jamie hiding behind am i not
allowed to do that
thank you sorry no echo on this one
hopefully um
a couple of things um if i could um you
mentioned that the science is evolving
very fast in china
one of the things that's come out um
recently is that there may be an oral
vaccine in prop
in in in preparation in china what do
you know about that
um if you could also tell us about how
um the two treatment trials are going
and particularly the hiv combo drugs
with
rem deserver and then just
also in the numbers that you've come up
with um dr
our director general ted rose
yesterday mentioned to us that there was
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you